okay good evening everybody and welcome
to tonight's planning committee meeting
my name is peter richards and i will be
chairing the meeting this evening and
some housekeeping if i may start with
we're not expecting a fire alarm if one
does go off please follow us out to the
car park next to the windmill and we
will just make sure that everyone is out
the building safely before letting you
go
mobile phones if you could please turn
them off
or at the very least is silent i don't
mind if you use them provided they don't
disturb the flow of the meeting the
meeting itself is a meeting in public it
is not a public meeting so only those
people that have registered speak will
be permitted to do so at the appropriate
time i will call you forward to sit at
one of the two desks in front of us uh
let you know your time um
and then uh it'll be over to you once
you're done if you could please give the
desk a quick wipe with one of the wipes
that are on on those desks and there's
also some hand sanitizer should you feel
the need to use that
let me introduce our officers so i could
so to my immediate right we have sophie
jarrett our committee services
representative and we have online our
solicitor ross chambers
and our planners are lanika agnew and
joe brook and we have david jefferies to
my immediate left who is our planning
manager david i believe you have a
statement to make i do thank you chair
my name is david jeffrey my role is to
provide impartial advice and to assist
members in their decision taking thank
you chair
marvelous thank you very much right
let's get into the full agenda so first
of all the disclosures of interest
remember does anyone have any
disclosures of interest councillor dixon
thank you chairman agenda item 6 which
is planning application 21-01926
i'm a very close neighbor and i'll be
taking no part in the committee at that
time
okay understood thank you very much i
think it's fair to say that we all know
uh the applicant through a role here for
uh item number three um i i'm certainly
here with no mind i am going to assume
that you all are as well
everyone has nodded so we will take that
as read and have that blanket disclosure
any others before we move on
no
okay minutes is everyone happy with the
minutes as presented um if they are i
will sign them off that's hands up
agreed everyone's good okay
right um now there is going to be a
slight change to the running order um
if if you bear with us while we go
through that so first of all um the
fourth item on our agenda which is
application
2102737 ful you'll see from the update
sheet that objections have been
withdrawn from the parish council and
therefore there is no need for that item
to be heard by the committee tonight so
that has been delegated um the next item
item number five which is application
2103 764 out we have no registered
speakers and in accordance with the
constitution we are permitted to
delegate could i have a show of hands
for those in favor of delegating please
that appears to be unanimous
yep that's unanimous now um and then uh
item i believe it's item number six as
uh council dixon has just referred
0 1 9 2 6 ful once again we have no
registered speakers and therefore um we
are permitted to delegate under the
constitution could i once again have a
show of hands for those in favor
marvelous thank you very much that is
unanimous okay let's dive into our first
item
forgive me i haven't done our apologies
could i it's not on our agenda items in
fairness but we will take some apologies
now please
thank you chairman we have apologies
from councillors adam and jennings
tonight marvelous thank you very much
now we will move into our first full
item which is application reference 2103
992 ful windmill farm and red horse fell
limited our presenting officer is lanika
agnew over to you
thank you chairman
so this planning application was
deferred on the 2nd of march in order
for legal clarification regarding the
possibility of restricting occupation of
both the existing dwelling on site and
proposed dwelling through a section 106
or condition
the application site of windmill farm is
located in the open countryside along
the a422 bamboo road and is marked by a
black dot on this map it is
approximately 1.6 miles from the village
of oxhil
the current use of the site is red horse
vale limited a family-run independent
local business selling domestic and
agricultural fuels as well as building
farm and equestrian suppliers the site
is industrial in nature with large metal
cloud storage buildings a paddock and
retail space the cartilage of the site
can be seen on screen
the application seeks to introduce a
two-story four bedrooms managers
dwelling to the west of the site and a
comprehensive security strategy
including cctv and fencing to support
the existing rural business of red horse
veil limited
the design of the proposed dwelling is
to have an l-shaped layout and be of red
brick with dark tile the total floor
area of the dwelling is 243 square
meters and could be seen in this slide
the application proposes a new route for
the public right of way to the western
boundary of the site as defined by
warwickshire county council public
rights away team public footpath ss-17c
intersects northwest through the
application site the agent has confirmed
that the existing recorded alignment of
the public footpath will remain open and
available for public use at all times
three new fence gates are also proposed
along the existing public right-of-way
as well as a two-meter high fence to the
northwest of the public footpath
this slide shows the existing access to
the industrial site and we can also see
the residential driveway accessed from
the banbury road
the new dwelling will use this existing
access point
this is a southeastern view of where the
proposed dwelling would be cited and as
shown there is an existing white
rendered dwelling on the application
site
the photograph was taken to the north of
the site and here the dwelling would be
site to the left of the storage
container this final slide shows the
existing industrial nature of the site
office is not satisfied that the
applicant has demonstrated a functional
and essential need for a rural worker to
live permanently on the site as there is
already an existing dwelling on the
application site
in conclusion the proposed dwelling
would be cited in an unsustainable
countryside location and is contrary to
policies cs1 and as10 and therefore
officers cannot support this application
and recommend that it is refused
furthermore the development management
consideration for as10i states a case
based solely on the grounds of security
will not necessarily be sufficient if
the application were to be granted this
argument of security could be repeated
on many of the rural sites and the open
countryside would become dotted with
isolated dwellings
thank you
thank you very much we'll call our first
speaker of the evening who is natasha de
silva
natasha good evening and welcome do you
come forward
now you'll have three minutes with a 30
second warning towards the end um
otherwise you're well versed with how
things run here it's over to you
good evening i am here to speak in
support of this application at red horse
vales this application was previously
heard at committee on the 2nd of march
and the applicant's wife mrs wally
hoggins spoke in support of the
proposals i do not think i could say
anything that better gets across the
need for the scheme for security and
management purposes so i would just
summarize her points
red horse fuels has a turnover in excess
of 15 million
it delivered 21 million litres of oil
last year
and it has a storage capacity of 450 000
liters of liquid fuel including kerosene
white and red diesel
it has tankers valued at 900 000 and 10
delivery vehicles valued at 300 000
the specialist nature of the business
means that there are several functions
that only can be carried out by
specially trained personnel including
accepting and properly storing fuel
deliveries only terry and marcus hoggins
have the required qualifications for
this
the above as well as the businesses
rural location means that it's
particularly susceptible to theft and
other risks associated with fuel supply
this second dwelling is being applied
for purely out of necessity rather than
choice as you can see from the photos
it's not exactly the best outlook
currently as only terry lives on site
many of the specialist responsibilities
fall to him where marcus also to live on
site this burden would be shared
terry has not taken a day off in four
years to ensure that the operation of
the business is not delayed in his
absence and that if there were to be an
issue someone was always on hand to deal
with it
policies cs22 and as-10 support
proposals with fos which fostered the
growth of the rural economy
red horse view red horse bales is an
established fuel and country supply
business running for over 60 years and
currently has 45 employees it is vital
that this business can continue to
operate sustainably having both brothers
living on site will not only support the
management of the existing business it
will allow them to increase trade and
expand going forward
this application was deferred so that
legal advice could be sought on applying
a condition to restrict obligation
occupation of both the existing and
proposed dwellings to persons working at
red horse fails
we do not necessarily agree that the
existing dwelling needs an occupancy
restriction as its physical connection
to the office and shop and location at
the center of the site means that it
would not be a desirable location to
live for someone not associated with the
business anyway however if members
deemed an occupational restriction for
both dwellings necessary we would accept
the condition we have discussed with the
case officer and agreed to a suitably
worded condition where the committee
minded to approve 30 seconds thank you
in summary there is a clear need for two
dwellings at windmill farm to manage and
future future-proof the business
um we hope that this is a
straightforward
decision to approve the scheme in line
with policy as10 and trust that members
will agree i am happy to answer any
questions you may have thank you
marvelous thank you very much members do
we have any questions mr silva please
counselor dixon
thank you chairman um
it's sad to hear that somebody hasn't
been able to take a holiday for so
long because of security issues
um but equally well um my assessment of
that uh volume is that is being proposed
is about two thousand square feet two
thousand five hundred square feet of
accommodation
uh has any alternative smaller up to
opportunity such as an annex to the
existing house been considered
sorry i didn't have my microphone on for
anyone at home um that was listening
that might be wanting to listen um
as i said we we have to look at what's
presented in front of us not something
that could or may have been considered
so i'm not going to allow that question
councillor crump please
hopefully you'll earn this one it's to
do with finance so uh my trump
bamboozled refinance rather than
planning and that page 13 um it was to
do with the security guard uh
potentially costing around about a
quarter of a million over 10 years
would that security guard
be
a straightforward security guard or
somebody who's got especially trained to
accept delivery so
what i'm trying to say is is that a
normal security guard or a security card
with enhanced capabilities
i mean when we were looking at those
numbers we were looking at a traditional
security guard
i
personally i don't know much about the
qualification the particulars of the
qualifications that would be more terry
and marcus's side i don't know how easy
it would be to come across somebody who
had those enhanced qualifications and
was a security guard but that's to be
honest that's kind of beyond my remit
i think yeah so it's probably slightly
an unfair question but you've answered
it really well it's just getting to the
fact that this it's a security guard
rather than somebody would be able to
potentially
yes accept deliveries of the specialist
thank you
council family
just to follow on from
councillor crump's question
i actually
brought this as a question the last time
we heard this
and we were told by the applicant
that it was a specialist
secure system they want somebody that
would turn up in a an escort run every
two hours and just have a walk around
the yard wasn't a sufficient sort of
sort of security they needed they needed
somebody who who would be able to react
to
sorry cancer flaming i'm just i'm going
to stop you there because it sounds like
that's for debate rather than now we're
looking at questions to the uh
applicant's agent now would anyone else
like to pose a question
no in that case thank you very much for
your time contribution
okay we'll call on believe it or not our
final speaker of the evening who is
cancer fielding cancer feeling come on
down you know the drill you'll have five
minutes with a 30 second warning use as
much as little as you wish
otherwise when you're already
uncomfortable it's over to you
thank you chair
um
first i'd like to point out that on page
11
there was the concern over
the 106 uh agreement the legal advice
was confirmed members minded to approve
the application on the basis of having
been demonstrated the business required
two dwellings
that i believe has
been accepted by
the applicant and from what i understand
it has been approved by
the legal eagles in the building
um
just going back on to
as10 the opportunity for business
development will be provided in the
countryside including farm-based
activities in accordance with as10
the expansion of
of the business
in the existing location will be
supported subject to the scale and type
of activities involved
the
basis of the and having been in the
security industry is that if you've got
security guards on site
they don't necessarily have the
same
approach to being as productive
as if you've got members of the family
who will be able to view any of the
problems
on the cctv screen and having
two members of the family one who can
check on the other if they're going out
to see a problem
in case it's a false alarm or if there's
a
more of a greater problem
they will be able to notify the police
or bring in or just basically state it's
a force alarm so you've got to
bear in mind that the police
felt that the dwelling will provide the
opportunities for detection and further
prevention of crime there's quite a bit
of crime in the area
um they're going around in them in the
villages at the moment pinching the
um platinum out of the exhaust systems
and cars
so
they do need to have proper
security set up there
and therefore basically i will go on
that that
working on cs10 working on
nppf 85 planning policies and decisions
should recognize the site to meet local
businesses and community needs in the
rural area many will be found adjacent
to existing settlements
the
this
business is very important
in the locality it not only provides
fuel it provides
agricultural
needs it provides fencing it provides
a lot of other items that are very much
a countryside requirement and they also
provide dried
timber for fires
so and
to go into stratford or to go into
lemington or to go into banbury there's
you know a quite a long distance and
therefore
with us with the district trying to deal
with the climate change element and keep
people off the roads it is very
important that the shorter journeys that
people do are the basis of what this is
i will leave it at that
that's philly thank you very much
members do we have any questions for our
ward member
council graham
yeah just very brief from that chairman
um
i should have asked the agent so the
agent might know this but as you're
close to the side john against the third
you might know um
it was mentioned at the last meeting
there was talk about expansion
of the of the business
and
it was implied or i felt it was implied
i might have misunderstood
that
this property
was pivotal towards that
expansion of the business
um
am i right in that or if i just
got it totally wrong and uh imagine that
i'm afraid
no i have discussed it with the
applicant
they
are looking to expand the business they
just need that extra security the ex
extra member of the family on site
because it's a family business
so the two brothers are partners in the
business so it's not and there is no
affordable homes in the area
so
they've either got to
drive from halford all the way up if
there's an alarm
so it is important that they are on site
thank you mr chairman has any other
questions for our ward member
no in that case cancer building thank
you very much time contribution
okay let's move to points of
clarification to our offices would
anyone like to have any points clarified
casa mills
thank you very much um
on the public right of way did you say
there was a fence going to be bill if i
got that wrong
did i mishear that
yeah there'll be a fence going out oh so
they're running a fence um
close to the dwelling
oh right so just on the one side so the
public right away people won't
they won't get disturbed um you won't be
altered yet thank you
anyone else
i'll try quite an important one i think
um so we've uh we've obviously within
your report you've referred to the fact
that we have had confirmation that
either a condition or an s106 uh could
tie the properties um i wonder if it's
worth exploring that now do you have any
wordings or any is it better through a
106 or condition and if you've got a
condition could we hear the wording for
the benefit of everyone before we go
into the debate please yeah absolutely
chairman so we feel that it's necessary
for a condition instead of a 106
and the condition will read as follows
the occupation of both the dwelling
hereby permitted and the existing
dwelling known as windmill farm cited on
the land edge red on survey location
plan drawing 210301
she'll be limited to a person solely or
mainly working or last working for the
business known as rail red horse veil
limited or a widow or widower of such
person and any resident dependents the
reason the site lies in the open
countryside where there is a general
presumption against new residential
development this proposal has been
permitted because it is considered that
there is justification for two dwellings
to serve the specialised needs of a
rural enterprise namely red horse bail
limited having regards policy as-10 of
the stratfor naval corps strategy and
paragraph 80 of the mppf
marvelous thank you and just from my
members that is written if we are minded
to grant um it's not a recommendation it
is if we are minded to grant okay let's
open up to debate who would like to kick
us off
i'm going to start pointing fingers
councilmembers are you first you have
smells pick it on me again mr chairman
um
yes i mean this was deferred from last
time and i i haven't
um
changed my mind um
on my vote from last time um
yeah
i've looked inside it it is a massive
site it's no doubt about it and um
i think with the extra security on there
i mean my
my neighbor uh being on holiday came
back and found their um oil tank have
been drained you know so i mean it's
going on now uh for the central heating
oil
and um
i mean it's quite vulnerable there it
was quite a open countryside um
the uh officer said it's one mile from
uh aomb i mean it's quite a long way
from aomb
um we've sorted out the
problem of the um
the ramblers
they can still ramble down there they
wish um
my mind mr chairman i i will go against
the office recommendation on this one uh
on on security i mean
uh
marcus um hoggins is an expert in
in dealing with any leakages or problems
that may arise that night can jump
straight on it so uh
i will go against obvious recommendation
and recommend that uh
we vote i've grant on this mr chairman
just one clear are you proposing that we
uh go against him grant yes i will do
marvellous we just need to make sure you
think about your wording for the reasons
you're going to get this recommendation
but i'll come back to you for that
counselor kendall next please
thank you chairman
um yes looking back on this my arguments
my concerns last time whether there
wasn't a strong enough case for the
security being needed i mind the cases
now have been created for that
and i was also concerned about the
status of the uh the existing property
that you've
thank you very much council fleming
yeah
echoing sort of what we're saying about
this security situation my concern is
if there was a leak not a fire but a
leak even it would be an environmental
disaster if you've got somebody that
pops in in their escort man every couple
of hours like i was saying earlier and
to have somebody on site who is
experienced is trained knows how to
react to that situation and i think
goes goes towards my reason to
to back up what council mills was saying
and on that basis alone i would i would
go against the officer's recommendations
okay lovely thank you very much can i
ask you to turn your microphone off
obviously thank you
anyone else before council crump
yeah just come in whether you need any
additional
reasons i think we could
again
promoting growth in the rural economy
and supporting a local business
whichever part of
whether that cs 10 or is 10 i can't
remember i've just tied so i can't
really remember but again i think growth
in the rural economy um
is just something that we should be
encouraging uh for for
for business um
successful business
and
um
the ward member
and i did get a nod from from the agent
in the background and said that this was
vital towards this growth as well it
would you know makes more
the need more fundamentals so
whether we could include that as well i
don't know
okay thank you very much unless anyone
else else has anything to say
um david are you comfortable that you've
with what you've heard and have reasons
uh yes chair i'm comfortable i've heard
um a number of reasons here um just to
clarify those would be that this is an
extremely large and unique site it's in
a vulnerable location in the countryside
and so it has a particular need for
security
members are concerned that there should
be
expertise for the industry on site
permanently
lovely stuff and just so we're clear
that extra condition will be included in
your proposal the one we heard earlier
about tying the two
properties
could we uh
perhaps run through conditions chair in
a moment
i'm not actually coming onto that on
conditions would permitted development
rights be removed because i'd be minded
to remove them on this
pd rights should only be removed in
exceptional circumstances
there will be limited pd rights on this
site as an industrial use uh for things
like hard standings for things like um
boundary enclosures
i think unless members have a particular
harm and a concern in mind that um
that could arise out of pd rights for
either the industrial use or the
dwelling here then officers wouldn't
recommend a removal of pd rights it's
it's not
the authority has
in the past removed pd rights and
suffered because of loss of appeals and
costs awarded against it because we
shouldn't do that arbitrarily we should
only do that in cases where there is an
exceptional likelihood that there's
going to be a fair harm convince me
okay marvelous um conditions um do you
have a list of conditions please
so there'll be 13 conditions altogether
see the time limit of three years
approved plans material schedule given
the prow and the open countryside
location
hard and soft landscaping
land contamination pre-commencement
remedial strategies
no site security fencing
um
make good use of any damage to the
public right-of-way electric vehicle
charging points water boots broadband
climate change checklist and the rural
workers tie and the occupants will be
tied to the business of red horse fair
limited
marvelous thank you very much okay so
members we have a proposal to grant for
the reasons given and with the
conditions we've just heard if i could
please have a show of hands for all
those in favor
that is all but one of us against
one abstentions none so committee
resolves therefore to grant application
2103 992 full
marvelous let's move on to our last and
final item of the evening which is
application reference
220089 ful20 main street in tiddington
our presenting officer will be joe brook
um as soon as he's comfortable on set
questions
time
thank you
the application site is located at 20
main street tinnington as indicated by
the black dot before you
the neighboring properties either side
of the application site are grade two
listed buildings the pros garage will be
cited on the side shared boundary of
number 18 main street so just for
reference application site within the
red line boundary listed buildings the
neighbouring sides and the garage will
be situated there on the shared boundary
number 18.
the applications for the replacement of
the existing single detached timber
garage with a detached brick and block
garage the proposed garage will be sited
on the same footprint as the one it is
to replace
no public views of the garage available
due to its location within the site
you can see that's the best violet
really as the proposed garage and the
existing one for the existing plans is
their same location
this is the existing uh garage as it is
uh corrugated timber um roofing and
timber cladding to mazat and i will show
you some photos for reference
this is a proposed garage supposed to be
set at 4.5 meters to ridge 3.1 meters to
eaves and it will be reclaimed brickwork
to match the existing house and natural
slate
this is the views coming down the
driveway of the dwelling so that's the
garage just there
this is views heading out onto the
public highway
the existing timber garage
as you can see cargo roof and timber
garden
same again so it shows the relationship
with the neighboring properties to rear
no overlooking windows you can see
including the conservatory
and once again there is one window here
looking down but not in any sort of
domineering position
same again neighbouring property looking
over it and you can see there oh
building in their area
in summary the pros guards will be cited
on the existing footprint as the
existing garage and the proposed
materials reclaim brick and slate will
match the host dwelling therefore it is
not considered to harm the existing
street scene character of the area and
the neighbour enlisted buildings
officer
is regard subject to the conditions as
notes are set out in the report
thank you
joe thank you very much we have no
speakers members so we'll move two
points clarification does anyone have
any points to clarify
no should we move into debate who would
like to kick us off counsellor kendall
thank you chairman it's a very pleasant
and sympathetic design seems to fit with
the area there's no objections from
anybody i'm happy to propose we support
and grant the application
thank you very much i will second that
would anyone else like to speak
no in that case we have a proposal to
grant in line with offers recommendation
could have a share of hands
that is unanimous so the committee
therefore resolves to grant application
2200 89ful
we have no virgin business so it reminds
me to thank you all for coming this
evening and everyone else that has
contributed
and our officers we'll see you next time
thanks very much